IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BACK IN THE
U.S. FOLLOWING HIS HISTORIC
SUMMIT IN SINGAPORE WITH
KIM JONG UN.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW SAYING THAT
NO NEED TO WORRY ABOUT A NUCLEAR
THREAT FROM NORTH KOREA.
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF IS ALSO
SITTING DOWN WITH BRET BAIER,
TELLING HIM U.S. COMBAT TROOPS
WILL REMAIN ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
>> IS THE MILITARY DRAWING DON
IN SOUTH KOREA?
YOU KIND OF HINTED AT THAT?
IS THERE GOING TO BE A
TIT-FOR-TAT?
>> NOT DRAWING DOWN AT ALL.
IT WAS NEVER DISCUSSED.
I'M SURE HE WOULD LIKE THAT.
IT WAS NEVER ON THE TABLE.
WITH THAT BEING UNDERSTOOD AND
YOU ASKING ME A QUESTION LIKE
THAT, I WOULD LOVE TO GET THE
MILITARY OUTAGES AND AS WE CAN
BECAUSE IT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY
AND A LOT OF MONEY FOR US.
WE DON'T GET PAID FULLY FOR IT.
I WILL BE TALKING TO SOUTH KOREA
ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE 32,000 SOLDIERS IN
SOUTH KOREA.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET THEM HOME
BUT IS NOT ON THE TABLE RIGHT
NOW.
>> Kimberly: THE FULL
INTERVIEW AIRS ON
"SPECIAL REPORT" TONIGHT AT
6:00 P.M. EASTERN.
IN SOUTH KOREA, SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO SAYS THE U.S.
WANTS TO SEE KIM JONG UN MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
DENUCLEARIZATION BEFORE THE END
OF TRUMP'S FIRST TERM.
THE PRESIDENT IS TAKING AIM AT
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOR
NEGATIVE COVERAGE OF HIS
LANDMARK SIT DOWN, TWEETING:
"SO FUNNY TO WATCH THE
FAKE NEWS, ESPECIALLY NBC
AND CNN.
THEY ARE FIGHTING HARD TO
DOWNPLAY THE DEAL WITH NORTH
KOREA.
500 DAYS AGO THEY WOULD HAVE
"BEGGED" FOR THIS DEAL.
LOOKED LIKE WAR WOULD BREAK OUT.
OUR COUNTRY'S BIGGEST ENEMY
IS THE FAKE NEWS SO EASILY
PROMULGATED BY FOOLS!"
GREG.
YOU ARE AN EXPERT IN
"PROMULGATED BY FOOLS."
>> Greg: I AM.
EVERYBODY HERE BY NATURE IS
SKEPTICAL.
WE ARE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
I FIND IT I GUESS FUNNY THAT THE
LEAST SKEPTICAL PEOPLE ON EARTH
ARE DEMANDING THAT WE BE
SKEPTICAL, SO THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT SMEAR YOU IF YOU ARE
SKEPTICAL ABOUT CUBA OR CLIMATE
CHANGE OR STATS ON MASS
SHOOTINGS.
IF YOU'RE SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE
PARIS ACCORDS, IRAN, COMMUNISM,
SOCIALISM, VENEZUELA.
IF YOU ARE SKEPTICAL ABOUT THAT,
YOU ARE HEARTLESS.
WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN SKEPTICAL.
I HAD MICHAEL MALICE ON MY
PODCAST TODAY.
HE TWEETED SOMETHING GOOD.
HE SAID THIS ON MY SHOW.
IF YOU THINK THE POSSIBILITY OF
PEACE IS WORSE THAN THE
POSSIBILITY OF WAR, THERE MUST
BE SOMETHING WRONG WITH YOU.
HE SAYS HE HAS A GOOD METAPHOR
THAT NORTH KOREA IS LIKE A
HOSTAGE SITUATION.
THE PROTOCOL IS YOU TRY TO GET
THE HOSTAGE TAKER TO PUT THE
GUNS DOWN AND YOU DO THAT FIRST
BY DIALOGUE, AND THEN, WHETHER
THAT MEANS REASSURING HIM WITH A
FILM, THAT MIGHT WORK.
IT'S TERRIBLE AND NORTH KOREA.
THEY HAVE CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THEY HAD GENOCIDE IN THE '90s.
IT'S A RUTHLESS REGIME.
CONTAINMENT DOESN'T WORK.
CONTAINMENT DOESN'T HELP THE
HOSTAGES FEEL GOOD.
A HOSTAGE AND MIGHT THINK TRUMP
IS SAVING ME.
>> Kimberly: DANA, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE IN TERMS, WE'VE HAD TIME
SINCE THE HISTORIC SUMMIT TO SEE
THE FALLOUT, THE DISCUSSION,
PEOPLE TAKE DIFFERENT SIDES IN
TERMS OF THEIR OPINION OF WHAT
THEY THINK TRANSPIRED.
>> Dana: I THINK IT IS STILL A
NET PLUS FOR THE PRESIDENT IN
THE WORLD.
THERE IS STILL HOPE.
THERE IS SKEPTICISM BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SKEPTIC PERKO SKEPTICISM ISN'T
NECESSARILY ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S ABOUT NORTH KOREA AND
KIM JONG UN BECAUSE THE REGIME
REPEATEDLY LIED.
THEY REPEATEDLY AGREED TO
SIMILAR THINGS BACK IN 1996,
2,000, 2006.
JOURNALISTS ARE SKEPTICAL.
CONSERVATIVES ARE SKEPTICAL.
THE SKEPTICISM IS ALSO ABOUT THE
NORTH KOREANS, JUST AS IT WAS
ABOUT THE IRANIANS.
I ALSO THINK THAT IN SOME WAYS
THERE'S THIS TRIBAL NATURE OF
WHO YOU'RE GOING TO TRUST.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT AND YOU
TRUSTED OBAMA AND YOU THOUGHT
THE IRAN DEAL WAS A GOOD ONE.
YOU MIGHT THINK THE PERSONNEL,
SECRETARY JOHN KERRY, YOU HAD
TRUST IN HIM.
CONSERVATIVES DID NOT.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING THE MIRROR
IMAGE.
REPUBLICANS WILL SAY A TRUST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I THINK HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S
DOING.
HE DIDN'T GET IT ALL IN ONE DAY.
WE DIDN'T EXPECT THAT.
THEY ALSO RESPECT THE PEOPLE AT
WORK FOR HIM.
JOHN BOLTON, MIKE POMPEO.
ON THE OTHER SIDE IT WOULD BE
BACK AND FORTH.
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COST TO AMERICANS TO HAVE OUR
TROOPS IN SOUTH KOREA AND IN THE
REGION AND TO DO THESE
EXERCISES, IT'S NOT JUST INPUT
OUT.
IT'S NOT A LOST CAUSE.
IT'S IN OUR STRATEGIC NATIONAL
INTEREST TO HAVE A PRESENCE
THERE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO RAMP
IT BACK UP.
THERE'S ALWAYS DANGERS LURKING
AROUND THE CORNER.
>> Kimberly: DANA BRINGS UP A
GOOD POINT ABOUT SOME OF THE
TRIBALISM ABOUT IT.
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO TRUST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PERHAPS THEY LOOKED AT THE OF
WHAT HE'S PROMISED AND WHAT HE'S
DELIVERED.
IS IT OKAY TO BE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT HAVING GOOD OUTCOMES?
TRUST BUT VERIFY.
>> Jesse: WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
BILLIONS OF CASH TO THE
AYATOLLAH.
THEY HAD A REALLY BAD TRADE WITH
BERGDAHL, HANDED OVER TALIBAN
MEMBERS.
THEY BOTCHED THE PARIS CLIMATE
DEAL, TPP.
THEY BOTCHED PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING THEY TOUCHED.
AND THEN TRUMP COMES IN TO TRY
TO BROKER A PEACE DEAL, GIVES UP
ALMOST NOTHING.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT PRAISED
OBAMA NOW ARE COMPLAINING.
CLINTON AND CARTER WENT OVER
THERE AND BUILT TWO NUCLEAR
REACTORS CAN WE GIVE THEM
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WHAT HAPPENS JUST THE OTHER DAY?
I THINK OBAMA GAVE TRUMP KEYS TO
THE WHITE HOUSE AND SAID BY THE
WAY, I'VE DONE NOTHING ON
NORTH KOREA FOR EIGHT YEARS.
IT'S THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT.
GOOD LUCK.
TRUMP TRIES TO BRING PEACE TO
THE PENINSULA AND ALL HE HEARS
IS 100% NEGATIVITY.
IT DESTROYS THE MEDIA NARRATIVE
THAT THESE THIS BIG WARMONGER.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S A DONE DEAL.
IT'S FAR FROM A DONE DEAL.
THERE IS POTENTIAL HERE FOR A
GREAT DEAL.
BUT THE DEPUTIES HAVE TO HANDLE
THE DETAILS NOW.
NO VERIFICATION, NO INSPECTIONS,
PHASEOUT IS UP IN THE AIR.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING
TO DESTROY THESE FACILITIES.
IT HAS TO BE HAMMERED OUT.
THE SPIRIT OF THE SUMMIT WAS
VERY STRONG IN THE POLITICAL
WILL BETWEEN THE TWO LEADERS
APPEARS TO BE VERY POSITIVE.
I THINK NOW WE LET THE LITTLE
GUYS HAMMER IT OUT AND WE WILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Kimberly: JUAN, THE
PRESIDENT USE RHETORIC THAT SOME
THOUGHT WAS INFLAMMATORY BUT HE
WAS SPECIFIC IN SAYING HE FEELS
IT PLAYED A PART IN TERMS OF
BRINGING NORTH KOREA TO THE
TABLE WERE ULTIMATELY HE USED
DIPLOMACY TO ACHIEVE THESE ENDS.
>> Juan: I READ IT
DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK HE SAID HE REGRETTED
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE HE IS USED
IN THE PAST.
>> Kimberly: HE SAID HE
THOUGHT IT WAS HELPFUL GETTING
TO THIS POINT.
>> Juan: I THINK HE SAID HE
REGRETTED IT AND UNDERSTOOD IT
WAS PROVOCATIVE LANGUAGE, IS
WHAT HE SAID.
TO THE LARGER POINT, I THINK THE
BIG NEWS TODAY IS YOU KNOW WHAT,
THE PENTAGON DIDN'T KNOW HE WAS
OFFERING TO GIVE UP MILITARY
EXERCISES WITH THE
SOUTH KOREANS.
MAYBE MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
SOUTH KOREANS DIDN'T KNOW IT.
THE SOUTH KOREANS HAVE PLAYED A
KEY ROLE IN TRYING TO MAKE THIS
DEAL HAPPEN.
THEY ARE SURPRISED TOO.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS KIND OF
SEAT-OF-THE-PANTS DONALD TRUMP
THINK THIS WILL WORK, THIS WILL
WORK.
WHAT ABOUT THE ALLIES?
THIS IS SOMETHING, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, YOU SAY AS
EVERYONE ELSE ON THE PANEL HAS
TALKED ABOUT, LET'S GO BACK AND
LOOK AT PAST CRITICISM OF
SOMETHING LIKE THE IRAN DEAL.
OH, MY GOSH.
AT THAT POINT, IT WAS SAID THIS
WOULD EVIDENCE OF OBAMA'S
INEXPERIENCE, THAT HE WAS A
CELEBRITY PRESIDENT AND DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE THREATS THE WORLD
FACE.
HE GOT A DEAL THAT STOPPED IRAN
FROM DEVELOPING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS NO SUCH
THING FROM PRESIDENT -- NO
GUARANTEE, NO METHOD OF
VERIFICATION.
NOBODY ON THE GROUND, NOR
ASSURANCES, NO DETAILS.
>> Jesse: IT'S BEEN TWO DAYS.
OBAMA HAD EIGHT YEARS.
>> Juan: THERE WAS A SIGNED
DEAL, JESSE.
THAT'S WHAT IT SAID.
NOTHING FROM THE NORTH KOREANS.
WHAT YOU GET IS WHEN OBAMA SAT
DOWN AND SAID I THINK THIS IS
'07, HE SAID I'M WILLING TO MEET
WITH PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT
REPRESSIVE REGIMES BECAUSE IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD BRIDGES,
TO TALK.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THE REPUBLICANS SAID WHAT'S HE
DOING?
HE IS CODDLING OUR ENEMIES AND
ALIENATING OUR ALLIES.
WHEN TRUMP DOES IT, OH, THIS IS
HISTORIC, AND THE AMERICAN MEDIA
IS THE ENEMY.
TALK ABOUT HYPOCRISY.
>> Jesse: I THINK WE HAVE A
STRONG, MUSCULAR, PRO-AMERICAN
PRESIDENT LIKE DONALD TRUMP WHEN
HE IS WILLING TO SIT DOWN AND
TALK TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES.
THERE IS A DIFFERENT POSTURE
THERE.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SOMEONE LIKE THAT AND SOME ELECT
OBAMA WHO DID AN APOLOGY TOUR,
TALKED DOWN AMERICAN GREATNESS
IN AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM.
AND HIS WILLING TO GO AND TALK
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUT
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUA
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUG
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUE
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUT
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CU,
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUV
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUG
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUL
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUN
TO AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NOT CUT
DEAL.
THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Kimberly: DOING AN APOLOGY
TOUR.
>> Juan: THE WASTE WAY YOU
>> Juan: THE WASTE WAY YOS
>> Juan: THE WASTE WAY YOE
>> Juan: THE WASTE WAY YOI
>> Juan: THE WASTE WAY YO
>> Juan: THE WASTE WAY YOS
ITS TEAM SPORTS.
I THINK LET'S GET AWAY FROM IT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A MOMENT
AGO.
130,000 PEOPLE LIVING IN GULAGS.
OUR TOUGH, STRONG PRESIDENT.
>> Kimberly: WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT IN 48 HOURS?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE THEY WOULD
COMPLAIN ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED THAT WAS VERY FAVORABLE
FOR THIS COUNTRY, FOR
NORTH KOREANS IN SOUTH KOREANS,
THE WORLD IN GENERAL, GIVE A
CHANCE FOR THIS TO WORK.
YOU DON'T LIKE IT IF WE GO TO
WAR.
YOU DON'T LIKE IT IF WE SIT DOWN
AND ENGAGE IN DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS.
>> Juan: OF COURSE I DO.
>> Dana: IF YOU ARE SKEPTICAL
OF ALL OF THIS AND YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO LOOK TO THAT YOU
RESPECT AND TRUST THAT IS NOT A
PARTISAN BUT IS AN EXPERT IN THE
REGION, VICTOR CHA IS A
GEORGETOWN PROFESSOR.
HE WAS GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S AMBASSADOR TO
SOUTH KOREA.
IT DIDN'T END UP WORKING OUT.
IF YOU READ HIS OP-ED IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TODAY, HE'S
PRETTY UPBEAT.
HE LIKES THE STRATEGY.
HE THINKS IT'S HEADED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
OF COURSE THERE'S A LIST OF THE
COMPLICATED QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
YET TO BE ANSWERED.
OVERALL HE'S QUITE UPBEAT AND
POSITIVE.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT PARTISAN COME HE'S A
GOOD ONE.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT TOTALLY
TRAVEL WITH ME, JUAN.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT
SUSPENDING THE WAR GAMES OR
MILITARY READINESS.
I THINK YOU NEED TO BE PREPARED
FOR THE NORTH KOREANS, AND
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THEM.
THEY ARE DEFENSIVE IN POSTURE.
THEY SEE THEM AS OFFENSE OF, THE
NORTH KOREANS.
WE WANT OUR ALLIES TO BE
PREPARED AND ON POINT.
SO WE CAN RATCHET THOSE BACK UP
AT ANY TIME.
THE BIG ONE ISN'T UNTIL SPRING
2019.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT HE DID IT IN
ORDER TO ENCOURAGE GOOD WELFARE
BUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING I'M CRAZY
ABOUT HAPPENING.
I WANT TO THESE TO CONTINUE.
I THINK THEY ARE IMPORTANT VERY
>> Juan: WISE THE PRESIDENT
THEN SAYING THAT KIM IS A FUNNY
GUY?
>> Jesse: WELL, HE IS FUNNY
LOOKING.
>> Greg: I FIND IT INTERESTING
THAT THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SPENT DECADES PLEADING FOR
DIALOGUE ARE NOW HAVING ONE
DELIVERED WITH A GIANT BOW.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT REALLY
HURTS.
LIBERALS HAVE BEEN PROMISING AND
CLAIMING IS THEIR EXPERTISE, AND
I THINK IT DISTURBS AND DESTROYS
THEIR SOUL TO SEE.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME TO SEE HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE AGAINST PEACE.
RETURN TO THE ANALOGY OF
HOSTAGES.
THERE ARE HOSTAGES IN THAT
COUNTRY, RIGHT?
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING IS
NEGOTIATING WITH THE HOSTAGE
TAKER WHICH IS EXACTLY THE
PROTOCOL THAT YOU DO.
IF IT DOESN'T WORK, YOU KNOW
THAT TRUMP GAVE THE HARD SELL.
YOU GO IN THERE AND RESCUE THE
HOSTAGES.
THAT'S THE POINT.
RESCUING THE HOSTAGES MEANS THEY
ARE GOING TO DIE.
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN DO
IT.
I AM OPTIMISTIC ABOUT IT BECAUSE
I THINK TRUMP IS GETTING THE
NORTH KOREAN REGIME TO THINK
PAST THE     SELL.
THE VIDEO IS BRILLIANT.
HE GOT KIM INTO THE CAR.
THAT WAS THE CORVETTE.
KIM GOT THE FEEL OF WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE IN AN AMERICAN CAR,
FREEDOM.
>> Kimberly: HE TOOK A LOOK
INSIDE.
HE MADE THE POINT.